andré grimaldi est professeur émérite de
médecine à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris est l'un des
signataires du manifeste du collectif
les jours heureux publié aujourd'hui
dans libération texte qui propose des
solutions à destination de l'exécutif en
vue de la refonte du système de santé
écoutez sa réaction notre système est
totalement inadapté à la fois la prise
en charge les urgences et encore plus en
cas d'épidémie on voyait avant avec les
mâles qui restent et les heures et 10
heures sur les brancards on l'a vu au
tpiy bronchiolite qu'ils aient pas plus
grave que les autres années avec des
dizaines d'enfants qui ont dû être
transférés à plus de 100 kilomètres de
parieurs en réanimation
évidemment avec les pyramides du coc
vise
et puis pour les mêmes raisons nos
systèmes dysfonctionne complètement pour
la prise en charge des maladies
chroniques 20 millions de patients parce
que le paiement à la comme la taille 4
activités sont inadaptés parce que la
concurrence est inadaptée et que un
service public
ça consiste justement à voir une
coordination pour permettre à toutes les
personnes d'avoir accès à des soins
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
or il ya une force logique commerciale
s'est mis dans la santé qui allaient
jusqu'à envisager avant le coc vide
le tourisme médical de haute gamme
disette ont donc c'est ça qu'il faut
revoir